Singapore is an exciting hot pot of Chinese, Malay and Indian cultures,...
...and the best way to experience this diversity is fabulous, boom, beautiful, insane food.
Let's go eat.
This is the essence of a Singapore breakfast right here.
You've got to break the yolks, mix it up.
Now here comes the magic.
Look at this Kaya toast.
So this is coconut jam,...
...a little bit of egg yolk and dip it right in there.
Wow!
Look at all the stuff in there.
Just going to dip this chicken murtabak into this spicy curry.
Wow!
Each bite is packed with flavor.
It's crispy, it's fluffy; it's just beyond delicious.
This is an Indian dish with a Singapore twist.
Look at this beautiful bowl.
It's a creamy, creamy laksa broth with cockles, fish cakes, laksa leaves...
...and a chili paste that you mix in.
We're going to try it out.
Oh, wow.
That's a flavor sensation.
It's spicy, sweet,...
...a little sour.
The cockles give it this really nice fishy flavor.
I'm in heaven.
Chili crab, wow!
Just look at how soft and delicate that claw meat is.
Singapore would not be Singapore without the chili crab.
I just can't talk anymore.
I just got to keep going here.